[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants je suis bien content
de vous voir au départ je suis donc
content de petitjean nounours est en
pleine forme ce soir il a préparé un
beau jeu à l'intention de nicolas et de
pimprenelle et de tous les enfants pas
trop rond je peux y aller oui oui
vas-y mon gros nounours
[Musique]
voilà pour les chats
le
des cendres voix
nicolas pas preneur
je vais leur tire mon soi j'ouvre la
fenêtre
et re centre son bruit je crois qu'ils
ont d'être tout surpris si je vois
disons cela
[Musique]
nous entrons de tapage nous dosser
message 2011 par les enfants sages mis
au jour
d'accord on va jouer au jeu de l'anneau
comme ces cas là écoutez moi bien les
enfants vous fermez bien les yeux
moi je vais cacher l'anneau que voici
quelque part où tout le monde peut le
voir et celui qu'il aura trouvé le
premier aura gagné ne triche pas nicolas
manteau jamais où est ce que je vais
dont le cacher c'est là peut-être nous
là non
que je suis beau être bannie mais ça y
est presque
attention feuilles sèches bambini chiens
non c'est très froid à je sens un petit
vent tiède qui souffre le ça devient
chaud c'est chaud ça brûle ou de
chatouiller c'est moi qui l'ait trouvé
un premier mois je gagne et non les
emplois le jeu est fini on se dispute
pas houleux lors mais le temps quel
enfant adorable
[Musique]
bonne nuit je petit ami l'a éteint la
lumière à donner
nicolas et pimprenelle tombe bien
[Musique]
alors les enfants vous êtes vous bien
amusé il en connaît de beaux jeux ces
nounours oh la la ce que l'on connaît et
du plus amusant encore dit patron si on
faisait une petite partie de me font de
lui une autre fois nounours je te
promets bonne nuit les enfants fait de
borel à demain à dogbo bonne
[Musique]